uh i don't know i mean i do understand
that that people do get
attached to this idea that we have nine
planets and that it does seem a bit of a
demotion
well the symbol for pluto is just a pnnl
put together
now pluto was a fairly recent discovery
it was only discovered in the 20th
century and although it has a name of a
roman god just like most of the other
planets with their associated very
ancient symbols i've always assumed
although i don't know for sure that the
symbol was just made up because it's
just a p and an l put together
which is both obviously the first two
letters of the name pluto but also
interestingly are the initials of
percival level and he was an astronomer
and it was it was at the level
observatory that they actually
discovered the planet
we have seen pluto we we've got pictures
of it from the hubble space telescope i
mean you can see it from the ground if
you know where to look
obviously it was discovered
with a telescope for the ground but i
believe that there is a mission on its
way called new horizons which is a space
mission
we have ignition and liftoff of nasa's
new horizons spacecraft on a decade-long
voyage to visit the planet pluto and
then beyond
which is actually going to fly fly by
pluto
and investigate what it's made up and
and the rest of this this newly
discovered system of bodies out there in
the outer reach of the solar system
called the kuiper belt so a couple years
ago at the international astronomy union
meeting they had a big get-together of
lots of astronomers from around the
world and debated at length whether or
not pluto should be called a planet or
not
now the the case against
is that it's very very unlike all the
other planets it has a different kind of
orbit it sort of sticks out of the plane
where all the other war
planets orbit around it's a lot smaller
it's a lot further away
and in recent years we've discovered
that there are many many other bodies
way out there in the outer solar system
the end result after a vote was that
pluto is no longer officially
a planet our solar system now has eight
official planets
but the bottom line is it doesn't matter
it doesn't make a difference to pluto
whether we call it a planet or not
nothing about pluto's fundamental nature
changes it's just a label that that we
choose to call it so i think it's it's
it's a bit of silliness really to be
debating this i don't care it's still
pluto
well it's very very cold obviously
because it's very very very far away
from the sun
um
and
um we know that it's a rocky body and
it's also got a moon and this is a bit
of of a strange thing because it's got a
moon that is a pretty large fraction of
its own mass
and this moon is called sharon or karen
depending on how how you pronounce it
and so the name of course pluto comes
from the god of the underworld the greek
god of the roman god of the underworld
and
karen was the the ferryman that would
ferry the the souls across the river
sticks into the underworld
so the name pluto was actually suggested
not by a professional astronomer but by
an 11 year old girl
and this
girl who became an and lived into a ripe
old age
unfortunately just passed away last week
i think as we're filming this or a
couple of weeks ago
her name was vinisha i'm not sure what
her last name was but
um when pluto was discovered it it was
the end of quite a long long search for
this mythical um or
hypo hypothesized uh extra planet um and
it made headlines around the world
and now it was the the prerogative of
the astronomers at the lowell
observatory to actually choose the name
um but they weren't coming up with with
very many uh acceptable
um ideas why not what were they coming
up with um i think one of the names was
after the wife of the director or
something like that you know nothing
particularly catchy
and this little girl living in england
at the time
read about this in the newspaper and
suggested to her grandfather
that pluto would be a good name
and her grandfather worked at oxford
university in the library he made this
suggestion to the professor of
astronomer astronomy there
and the suggestion made it back across
to to the lowell observatory and in the
end they voted on three different names
i'm not sure what the other two were but
pluto got all of the votes in that
competition
now of course a lot of people know the
name pluto as being the name of disney
character
and many people think that the planet
was actually named after the disney
character but in fact it's the other way
around the planet came first and pluto
the dog came later back when pluto was
considered a planet
it was
at some times closer to the sun than
neptune was
so it wasn't the furthest planet and the
reason for this is another thing that
makes pluto quite odd relative to the
other planets is that most of the
planets orbit the sun in the plane of
the ecliptic so if you look down on the
solar system they all kind of happily
live in this nice disk
around the sun but pluto doesn't pluto
is oriented like this so it's got this
big elliptical orbit that sort of
plunges through the plane of the
ecliptic so in certain configurations
you can imagine that
during the relative orbits of pluto and
neptune sometimes pluto could be a
little bit closer to the sun than
neptune could be so the kuiper belt
objects are just this collection of
objects in the very outer reaches of the
solar system and you can think of them
as just the the remnants of what's left
over after planet formation so just a
lot of junk out there a lot of rock a
lot of icy bodies
and we just haven't found them until
recently because obviously they're very
very far away and they're very dim and
they're very hard to find so you're
saying pluto is just a big piece of junk
oh and then don't put words in my mouth
i'll go as far as to say that no it
probably isn't isn't a planet but i'm
not going to slander it by calling it a
piece of junk it's an interesting part
of our solar system